Welcome back everyone they dropped a brand new
house of the dragon trailer we'll break it down
there's a bunch of easter eggs here george r
martin talking a lot about the history of the
dance of the dragons also going back to aegon's
conquest and eventually what happens during a song
of ice and fire in the main novels during the
events of the original series game of thrones
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos i already did
an early non-spoilery review of episode one so
i'll post a link for that at the end of this and
down in the description below but just starting
at the beginning of this when viserys the first
targaryen says the dragons are going to rule over
the next hundred years that basically takes us to
the events of the second blackfyre rebellion in
the reign of daren ii targaryen there are a couple
reasons why the next hundred years are kind of a
loaded term because it references a lot of things
that they also referenced during the main series
in game of thrones much later in the timeline
during both of the blackfyre rebellions the
bloodraven was a big figure who becomes the
three-eyed raven it is the three-eyed raven his
real name was brynden rivers he was a targaryen
bastard and also maester aemon was a targaryen
maester eamon was alive during the events of
the second blackfyre rebellion that's how old he
is that you have two targaryens basically living
up at the wall during the events of the main
series the other funny easter egg here at the
beginning of the trailer when viserys the first
talks about how dragons are gonna rule over the
next hundred years just like they have over the
hundred previous to this the actual last dragon
was actually born during the reign of aegon the
third targaryen the son of ranira targaryen his
daughter like who we see on the main show here
in daemon targaryen now he's not born to like way
later in the timeline so we don't see him during
the first couple of episodes but eventually we'll
see his birth during the events of the series
there's actually a lot of time that passes during
the events of house of the dragon way more time
passes than you saw past during the events of the
main series game of thrones that's why they have
different actresses playing the young versions
of rhaenyra and alicent hightower because when
you see the older versions it's like way later
in the timeline in when viserys the first of the
dragons ruled the previous hundred years that's
also aegon's conquest that took place about a
hundred years ago george r martin talks a lot
about the actual history of westeros before the
events of the series after aegon's conquest just
showing you how king's landing itself grew really
fast during that period we see the older version
of jiharis the first he's the fourth targaryen
king in westeros after aegon the conqueror
they called him jiharis the wise just because
his rule was a period of great prosperity but
then they show you all this imagery of the burning
heart tree the weirwood here you actually see the
heart tree in king's landing in the godswood of
king's landing during the events of the series
they're lying under it here there was a heart tree
there is a god's wood in king's landing you just
don't see it that much during the events of the
main series and the tree has been burned down
by the events of the main series this is sort of
meant to remind you about the events of the main
series the prophecy of a song of ice and fire
the long night the coming of the night king the
white walkers that's briefly referenced during
the events of house of the dragon but remember
the events on this series predate the events
of the second long night that we see during the
main series by so much that even though the night
king is active during this period in the lands of
always winter like there are white walkers there
are whites they're just not very active they're
more of a myth at this point in the timeline
nobody's actually seen them in a long time so long
so that the people of the realm have basically
forgotten the original reason why they created
the wall they started to think now that it's
actually to keep the free folk out of the seven
kingdoms like no no that's not why we built the
wall we built it to keep away the white walkers
you also get a little bit of history behind the
hightowers and the velayrons who are big houses
during the events of this series fun fact too they
were actually still around during the events of
the main series game of thrones dan and dave just
cut them out of the original show what actually
happened is during robert's rebellion after he won
and took the iron throne he replaced the current
lord velayron at that time as master of ships with
his brother stannis and the hightower still ruled
over old town so during the war of the five kings
during the second long night like all the really
crazy stuff that happened during the original show
those two houses the valerians and the hightowers
are still around they're just not as active in the
main events that took place they'll probably be a
little bit of confusion about that when the show
picks up for people that don't read the books like
where were these people when the events of the
main series took place no they were around like
they just cut them out of the show basically as
you said the velayrons actually are of valyrian
blood so just to be clear the velayrons and the
valyrians are two completely different concepts
like the targaryens and the velayrons are both
a valyrian descent ages of the valerions were
not dragon riders and they went to westeros long
before the targaryens did and basically controlled
all trade between westeros and the valyrian
freehold which is how they became so rich by
the events of this series the valyrians had become
a vassal house of house targaryen because of what
happened during aegon's conquest and the other
really cool thing that george r martin reveals
is why the targaryens settled on dragonstone
instead of settling on the mainland of westeros
it was all because of daenys the dreamer's dragon
dreams in the prophecy of a song of ice and fire
daenys the dreamer had her dragon dreams for
seeing a couple different major cataclysmic
events one of them being the long night eventually
but she's mostly known for having the dragon dream
that foresaw the doom of valyria which is the
whole reason why they initially left the ancient
valyrian freehold to come to westeros so as a
measure of caution they settled on dragonstone
also the second reason for them settling on
dragonstone was because of the current state of
the seven kingdoms because it would start a really
big war if like a giant family with a whole bunch
of dragons just suddenly settled in someone else's
territory they briefly touch on the idea of dragon
dreams during the events of the house of dragon
episode 1. i'll talk about that when i do like my
full easter egg video for episode one there are a
lot of things that they reference in passing but a
lot of episode one is just table setting and just
kind of setting up a lot of the big concepts that
they'll explore during the events of the series
episode one is going to be released in a couple
weeks like i said i'll do videos for all the
episodes like i did for the main series so make
sure you enable alerts for my channel so you don't
miss that if you have any big questions or things
that i haven't covered in my previous trailer
videos just write them below in the comments and
i'll add them to my list of bonus videos everyone
click here for my non-spoilery house of the dragon
episode 1 review video and click here for my black
panther wakanda forever trailer video in easter
eggs thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!